[Music]
all right let's go to lauren in denver
colorado what's up lauren
hey john thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for getting up super early
on the
western side of america
no worries
um so i am in a situation where i feel
like every day i feel like very stressed
and anxious
and it's i just i don't see the light at
the end of the tunnel i work full-time
my husband works full-time we have two
little kids and it just feels like every
week some new
negative thing pops up into our life
that we have to deal with and uh i think
it's definitely becoming obvious like my
husband he's not stupid he knows
something's wrong he asks i sugarcoat it
and we kind of move on with the week and
uh we were gifted an opportunity coming
up where we get to have dinner and
somebody else is watching our kids for
us and he thought this would be a great
time for us to have a conversation of
like
what do you want what do i want what do
we want for the future for our family
and i am just like terrified that he's
going to bring it up that i seem anxious
and stressed and he wants to know what's
wrong and i don't know how to
communicate that to him
so i was hoping to get your advice on
that
yes
you just described millions and millions
of people and so thank you for having
the courage to call um this conversation
i think can help a lot of people so
thank you so much
um
so let's take the reality of stress okay
how old are your kids
uh three and one three and one
so
the call
you feeling stress to the three and a
one year old 100 hear me say completely
normal okay
and like your whole world's exploded
somebody throw a grenade in the middle
of your house and you have a three and a
one-year-old and
there's insane financial pressures right
now right
yes and you live in a really expensive
part of the country right
yes
and
you and your husband how long have you
been married
uh
almost four years okay
and how long did y'all date before that
uh
two or three years i think two or three
years okay so you got pregnant pretty
quick after you got married is that
right
yes okay so let's go back to the first
few months when it was we can just do
whatever we want whenever we want
or maybe there's this moment where
you've never been able to just do
whatever you want whenever you want
because you got married and then you got
pregnant and then it's
now the trains left the station if you
will
all i have to say is this the stresses
you are feeling are very very real
who are we is this what our marriage is
gonna look like um we have sex annually
now instead of daily right like all
these things shift and change
and
are you gonna go to work all the time
are you gonna get frustrated you're
gonna try to fix it all those things are
real okay so i want to say all the
stress is real
when it comes to the anxiety describe
that for me tell me about it
so um we are on a debt-free journey and
we will be consumer debt free december
1st the reason i think that i have so
much anxiety around that is like we
we're married we have joint income like
joint checking all that but the bulk of
that income comes from my paycheck and
so my husband like if he lost his job it
would suck but we we would survive our
bills would get paid on time if i lost
my job that would not be the case um so
that part stresses me out and then makes
me anxious that like something could
happen because
um i have a very flexible job i have a
work from home job great employer my
husband does not have that so if
something happens with the kids like
with school starting up we just found
out they won't get a bus they won't get
before school care there's no
after-school care because of low
staffing so i have to rearrange my
schedule at work and then that makes me
anxious that like i'm not a good
employee and like what if i lost my job
but i have to do all these things for
the kids because all these services that
we were planning on relying on just got
taken away
so you sound like a single mom with
three kids
sometimes it feels like that and i think
my husband knows that and he doesn't
like that he's just he's in the trades
and in his industry it's like fathers
don't exist they just you know he took
time off he took a day off when my son
had surgery and he caught so much flack
from it i saw the text he was getting
from his boss and it was it's horrible
like he needs to make it
he used to quit that job
okay it won't cost joe any money he
needs to quit that job
and he's to go be around a culture of
tradesmen that will
love and honor him as a dad and as a
husband and as an employee
and they do exist because i know them
personally
um you want to see a room full of teary
big bellied um sweaty men
like uh get a group of tradesmen in a
room when one of their buddies is having
a baby
it's one of the coolest things you'll
ever see or when somebody when they all
show up to the hospital to be with
somebody whose wife just passed away um
i've been in there too it's it's
unbelievable the amount of emotion and
love in there so your husband's it's not
the industry he's got a crappy situation
his boss sucks bus is terrible okay
um he's not on the phone with me so i'm
just going to talk to you okay
what you're doing is being dishonest
with him
you're not telling him the truth
and what happens is when you you don't
tell him what you need what you're
scared about what you're anxious about
and you swallow all that and sit on it
he like you mentioned he knows y'all are
disconnected
and the problem is he thinks it's him
and a part of it might be him the fact
that he doesn't make enough money and
that y'all have a lifestyle that's not
sustainable if one of you lost your job
all that kind of stuff or that you are
having to do all the work you just
mentioned plus laundry plus keep the
kids bathed and do bedtime and all that
but if you don't sit down and say here's
what i need
i need us to reconnect i need us to
figure out what intimacy looks like with
a three and a one year old i need you to
help me with bedtime i need like if i
need here's my list of needs
um if you don't do that
um
i think it's it's dishonest it's just
not fair
yeah right what is it about your needs
that you feel like cannot be told cannot
be said is he going to get mad is he
going to hit you is he going to scream
why won't you tell him
so he doesn't really get mad he feels
guilty he has an immense amount of guilt
going into the trades his family was
very anti-trades um they looked down on
him for it and i was like the first
person to come in his life that was the
opposite i said i love that you're in
the trades like that's huge for our kids
to know that they don't have to go to a
four-year traditional college like i
love that and i feel like if i try to
explain him the stress that i have it's
going to go back to him feeling guilty
that he'd never finish college him
feeling guilty that he's not bringing
home enough money or the teacher
look at the world you've just created
okay
i'm the first person to tell them that
trades are okay and they're noble and
they're great and by the way they are
and
he's not making enough money for me to
feel safe at home
and he's so busy that he can't help with
anything at home so you want your kids
to like see their dad and be like you
can do anything you don't even have to
go to four-year college and by the way
this is gonna create a life that makes
it really hard for parents to be
connected and safe
yeah that makes sense see what i'm
saying
so you're you're you're cheering a
football player that's not working
now this isn't me bagging on the trades
this is that your husband has
picked a company in a group that aren't
paying and what he's worth because the
numbers we're getting here on trades or
through the roof what does he do what
kind of trade does he actually do
oh so he's a car he was a carpenter now
he's a site supervisor okay
um he needs to go get another job
okay
like asap
and a job that doubles or triples or
quadruples his income
and here's the hard hard thing for you
as a wife to hear
you cannot solve and fix his guilt
you can only tell him the truth and it
with with dignity and respect
okay okay
you trying to protect him makes you his
mother not his wife
yeah that makes sense are you trying to
pray and who and i say this with all due
respect but he wants to sleep with their
son who wants to who wants to sleep with
their mom right so it creates a really
weird intimacy dynamic
when he's looking for you to feel less
guilty
and you have to pat him on the head and
say it'll be okay
and then he goes to bed after three
beers on the couch and i'm just making
this up who knows he may be a great guy
um but then you have to go figure out
how to do laundry see what i'm saying
like
it's just none of this is true and then
let me let me be real honest with you
this ends badly
in one of two ways
one of you is going to over time seek
connection elsewhere
whether it's from alcohol whether it's
from a second drink whether it's from
somebody at work that's really funny and
thinks you're funny too that or
what i'm coming to believe is worse
is you'll both find yourselves on
opposite recliners staring at a big flat
screen tv
and that would be your 40s and 50s and
60s and then you won't have the energy
to roll around with your grandkids and
that'll just we'll just call it a life
after that
[Music]
yeah that kind of feels like where it's
headed yeah right right
so
let's stop that train for at least a
station
you got a three and a one-year-old this
is the and your husband's actually doing
the super right thing which is all right
we got a three-year-old a one-year-old
we've been married for like two months
without being without being pregnant or
with kids
let's let's get ahead of this and let's
create the marriage that we want
let's say all the things how it's going
to look let's go make that happen
and i think it's
less about hey honey you need to go make
more money
this is you saying i see a gr is he a
hard worker
yes is he good at what he does he's a
good carpenter yes um good supervisor
takes care of his man he loves his guys
yes definitely okay
this conversation looks like this
um
honey i see how good you are with your
the men and women that report to you i
see how good you are coming under budget
you're incredible teacher you're a great
uh whatever uh carpenter
and where you work i'm sick of watching
a group of people not value you i'm
asking you as your wife to go find
somebody who will value you both
financially and your expertise and your
most important calling which is being a
dad and a husband
is that you see i'm saying that
that's different than you got to go make
more money because one of those is like
there goes the shame conversation the
other is hey we pick this i'm all in
um they don't value you
and i'm tired of seeing the man that i
love not be valued
i think that would help the one area i'm
a little bit concerned on very early in
our marriage my daughter was three
months old and he he has a history of
job hopping prior to that he was not
great with jobs uh he would get you know
mad at a boss and walk off the job site
and when my daughter was three months
old he did that
and it turned into a huge fight and i
accused him of job hopping and he got a
new job and hasn't done that since then
so i think it's going to be a new
perspective him hearing me tell him to
go get a new job but i think he'll be
happy
he might but also he acted like a child
that was a temper tantrum
yeah right that was a third grader
temper tantrum again going back to you
you're a single mom with three kids
and it may even be that he got into the
trades not because he's got this calling
to be a carpenter or a plumber which is
a noble incredible profession but
ain't gonna tell me i'm going to college
i'm gonna go do this you see what i'm
saying
yeah and so
um
people in his life might have told him
no dude you were put on earth to be a
surgeon or you were put on earth to be a
computer programmer
and yet you ran into a couple of
professors that were mean you didn't get
straight a's you had to work really hard
or whatever the thing is and he's like
i'm out of here and quit that just like
you quit the job site number one and job
site number two
yeah and so there is no shame
none zero
of saying okay cool i didn't go finish
college i went and ran the trades and
i'm now at the top of what i can do in
my area and i make 33 000 which i don't
buy by the way but let's just say that's
that's the truth
uh-huh there's no shame in going back to
school
there's no shame in saying okay what do
we want to do now let's just let's pivot
let's do something different right you
see what i'm saying and giving him the
freedom to do that but he has to have a
job
right that makes sense okay um you
cannot allow his
well i just feel guilty and set
that's not an excuse you got to tell
them hey i can't carry this whole house
and i'd rather be your wife
than your mom
is that cool
yeah i think that sounds good are you
gonna actually do this are you gonna
chicken out
i think honestly
because we have the chance i think
you're gonna have say none of this stuff
i think you're gonna say no it's good i
just i just um i need to get in the gym
more and he'll be like okay and then
that'll be it
so normally that probably is how the
conversation would go but because we got
this opportunity to go to a restaurant
and you know there's obviously drinks
involved i'm sure i'd be more likely to
actually tell them the truth
oh
nothing sounds like romance like i'll
tell them the truth and i've been
drinking
way to go lauren that's love love love
um it's super not but you know what i
mean so
do me a favor write this stuff down
before you go because you're going to
get nervous and you're going to forget
and he's going to make faces or you're
going to see that that grimace
of
of guilt or i'm so sorry i should have
been i know i did and you need to tell
him hey let me finish this i want you to
write it all down okay
and if he's struggling in that
conversation or he hears some things
that are hard for him to hear
um and he wants to act like a child
about it throw a temper tantrum about it
um
then i want you to have him call me okay
i don't think he's going too far i'm
hoping he hears you
i'm hoping you can sit down at the table
and say dude i'm super excited to build
a life that we want that's going to be
different than any of our parents had
we're going to make this up and
not as we go but we're going to plan and
we're going to go get there
and uh we're going to go make this thing
happen and it's going to start with you
going back to school or you get a new
job where they honor you i'm going to
stop having to do all this work because
you're going to be a co-helper in this
home
and we're going to get our sexy back
yeah and we're going to do we're just
going to make it happen all right hey
i'm going to send you a copy i'm sending
you two copies of redefining anxiety my
book on anxiety and you and your husband
can read through it together and this
got the three points there about
connection about being scared and about
autonomy like we're in control of what
comes next and y'all could talk through
those things as you build this new life
i'm excited to find out how this
conversation goes uh get back in touch
with me let me know how it goes i can't
wait to hear about it